since its emergence in Wuhan China the
corona virus pandemic has tightened its
grip on the world six months ago the
w-h-o announced that the corona virus
could spread between people now is
reached almost every country in the
world shutting down economies and
forcing whole continents to enact
emergency responses the most rapid
spread of the virus is now in South
America to date there have been 14
million infections and 600,000 deaths
and this number is rising every day the
global scientific machine has jumped
into action and scientists have learned
a lot about the virus but there are
still many questions researchers are
working to answer why do people respond
so differently to infection
different people have strikingly
different responses to cope it 19
infection some never develop symptoms
whereas other seemingly healthy people
have severe and sometimes fatal
pneumonias there are multiple teams of
researchers investigating the
possibility that there could be a
genetic component the first strong
genetic links to severe kovat 19
suggested the people who developed
respiratory failure are more likely to
carry either one of two gene variants
these variations only seem to play a
small part in the disease but it's hoped
that further research will uncover more
significant genetic markers for severe
symptoms many studies have also shown
striking variations between social and
ethnic groups the causes of these
disparities are not clear but it is
likely that they're linked to
socio-economic inequality can we develop
immunity and if so how long does it last
this is a big question and immunologists
are working feverishly to determine what
immunity to SARS cough to could
studies have found that the immune
system can create high levels of
neutralizing antibodies against SARS
cough - which remain high for a few
weeks after infection but then typically
begin to wane
antibodies might linger higher levels
for longer when people have suffered a
more severe infection but researchers
still don't know the level of
neutralizing antibodies needed to
prevent reinfection or reduce kovat 19
symptoms ultimately antibodies are just
one part of the immunity story other
immune cells called t-cells are
important for long-term immunity -
researchers must piece together this
patchwork of immune responses and
compare them with infections from other
viruses to estimate how durable
protection might be
as the virus developed any worrying
mutations all viruses mutate as they
infect people and SARS cough - is no
exception
molecular epidemiologists have used
these mutations to trace the global
spread of the virus but scientists are
also on the lookout for changes that
affect the properties of the virus for
instance making it more or less virulent
or transmissible identifying worrying
mutations is tricky as most changes
won't affect how the virus spreads in
humans in fact these mutations won't
become apparent until the virus needs to
mutate to survive and that won't happen
until most of the world's population has
been infected or developed immunity how
well will a vaccine work an effective
vaccine may be the only way out of the
pandemic there are currently about 200
candidates in development worldwide with
around a dozen in clinical trials
several of which have already reported
that their vaccines seem safe the first
large-scale efficacy trials are set to
begin this summer but data from early
stage human trials and animal studies
seem tentatively hopeful studies in
macaques suggests that vaccines may do a
good job preventing lung infection but
not elsewhere in the body such as the
nose results such as this raised the
possibility of a COBIT 19 vaccine that
prevents severe disease but not the
spread of the virus what is the origin
of the virus most researchers now agree
that SARS cough - originated in
horseshoe bats but it's not yet known if
it jumped directly from bats to humans
rat g30 a coronavirus found in bats is
96% identical to SARS cough - but that
4% difference
represents decades of evolution possibly
in an intermediary species according to
some researchers this could be Malayan
pangolins but to unequivocally trace the
virus's journey to people scientists
would need to find an almost identical
version in an animal a prospect that is
further complicated by the fact that the
virus has been shown to spread back from
people to animals with cats dogs and
farmed minks all showing signs of
infection more than six months after the
emergence of kovat 19 scientists
continue to search for answers and while
progress has been made it's clear there
is still a long road ahead
[Music]